we're here in atlanta radio rose site of
super bowl 53 is just coming up in a few
days and joining us now a guy who has
had two great nfl seasons and still a
young young he's younger than mine sons
crazy juju smith schuster team mvp of
the pittsburgh steelers with us here at
pft live juju how are you buddy i'm
doing great man it's a blessing to be
here to have this opportunity uh just to
be on the show
how has your career exceeded
what your expectations were coming in
super super high than what i expected uh
just because you know
you know it went into my rookie year you
know second round um drafted by the
sitters you know a guy like a b on her
team
you know i i didn't didn't didn't really
see it you know see to get the ball as
much or you know get the yards and i
think as time time goes on year two was
kind of like
wow this is really happening you know
eye opening so it's been awesome to see
what's been going on what about like i'm
so impressed with you as a person first
of all you're like you're amazing on
instagram everything like that how do
you kind of balance it all did you know
you had a gift with with all this stuff
well how i saw it on social media i
didn't start switching means i got to
college right like midway through
college yeah and i was like man you know
people can always go down by snap off of
just one post and i always thought as a
positive side like man
why can't athletes be
themselves and have other hobbies and
post other stuff that they're interested
in instead of just their main sport so
football players we always hear about
football working out working out posting
working on posting working out where
like for myself i'mma post a video of me
singing baby shark that a lot of kids
know are doing dances celebrations right
all the fun things well that's where
like my little boy i mean you with
fortnite i mean he knows about that i
mean first of all video games do you
think they help you with playing
football like when you play madden or
for sure for sure the communication you
gotta you know the hot the architecture
yeah so those are all you know helping
uh more sort of communication because
you organize you work as a team you get
the big three right in like football
yeah right i've lived around pittsburgh
most of my life and there's been a
handful of athletes who have come to
town and just instantly grabbed the soul
of the city i think back to frank
o'hara's that's way before your time
that's even before your time but guys
like mario lemieux i mean guys who have
become part of the fabric of pittsburgh
and i feel that happening with you
already tell me from your perspective
how you sense that connection you've
made in pittsburgh and how strong it is
man the the connection is amazing the
fan base the southern nation fans are
unbelievable supporters uh whether up or
down
and it's all started off with the bike
then getting licensed and my dog but the
biggest one of all was the birth hit and
that that's right there like grabbed the
whole cell nation and pretty much they
wrapped me around their arms and you
know they supported me since day one
that's interesting the perfect hit that
that got the steeler nation to love you
yes yeah that was a good hit oh thank
you so it was well worth the money yeah
yes it was
and then speaking of money i mean you
you've got
a huge portfolio of marketing partners
already after only two seasons and a lot
of guys don't have that like do you
sense any players in the league kind of
union he's big time he was you know he's
a rookie two years ago here comes juju
smith schuster everybody loves him now
do you get any of that resentment from
other players oh yeah i mean a lot of
players uh you know talk and say who's
the marketing guy who does this
and honestly i run my own marketing i do
everything in house i have two people
who who help me uh but there's no agency
involved and it's more so like just i
always associate myself with a brand
that i know that fits for me that's real
for me so it's been fun what's your
thought on how the saints got screwed
over a little bit at the end of the game
i got another part to this question
after you say that then it's tough man
as often as a player everybody would say
but honestly i believe that the rams
everybody knows on the rams everybody in
the world knows it was a bad call
with a call like that that's like
literally
wide open and you know the answer to
that call um to be overturned that
should be reviewed um
i mean should you review every call i
don't think so because the games would
be four hours long instead of being like
two and a half three hours right so yeah
but so okay where i was going with it
too is like okay past interference
missed calls happen and i want to i talk
about like your pittsburgh new orleans
game right they got two bullcrap pass
interferences you guys got called on you
when i'm fourth down i don't know i mean
you just it's part of football i guess
that's where i was going i've had better
questions i guess but
[Laughter]
hey how much have you learned from
antonio brown in all respects because
you know the work ethic's legendary but
you've been able to study him and watch
him what lessons have you picked up from
him
man the the one of the main reasons and
lessons i learned from tony brown is how
hungry he is i mean for him this is year
nine year ten and he's been hungry since
day one um he goes out there he works
his butt off every day and that's
something i see and i embrace um
outside of football uh you know we're
always talking about you know like
you know what deals what's going on like
what do you see yourself later in life
and man antonio brown man he's gonna
play a lot of years he's still got his
time on his belt is he playing any more
years in pittsburgh yeah you think it's
salvageable do you think it is
i don't think he's going nowhere else
yeah you do you really think that this
can work out i really think it can work
out i mean his career has been amazing
right the past nine years i mean why
would you leave but what do you do as a
guy who's only got two years in you're
still you know a lot of veteran players
there guys been there longer than but
before you're even in college guys that
have been do you just kind of like stay
out of it or do you try to find a way to
play peacemaker and get everybody on the
same page i'm playing peacemaker i've
been playing peacemaker since yesterday
yeah you have everybody's been asking me
this question and i want everybody to
come back to le'veon bell to a b and
let's go into super bowl but le'veon
bell's not coming back right
we'll see what do you think it's fair
that mike tomlin sometimes takes the
brunt of all this blame like
i just feel like he's kind of falsely
accused at times
yeah i mean it's tough i mean his
situation as being a head coach that's
something that you have to you know be
accountable for at some times uh in life
but yes i think that's how it is
what do you got going on with gatorade
so with gatorade uh this is a product
you know obviously another a huge brand
legendary brand that i've been working
with it's it's helped me throughout my
uh career obviously
um
my best ability on the field off the
field i've been uh this is gatorade zero
it's a new product
and with all the electrolytes that you
need that i need yeah no sugar
zero sugar involved and if you guys want
to
get a promo code i'm gonna tell you guys
a little secret okay gatorade
sb
get 20 off use it data rate sb theater
sb now you know they stuff with zero
sugar they say it doesn't taste very
good are you saying this tastes good
all right i'll take it all right now to
the hard-hitting stuff the hard-hitting
stuff okay yes we're in atlanta
hip-hop capital third that tastes good
there you go
don't do that okay all right here we go
finish this lyric for me all right
stacks on deck patron on ice we can pop
bottles
all day all night no ah
ti you can have whatever you like
yeah you knew it i'm not gonna sing so
you're just gonna have to figure it out
okay i am not a singer or a rapper
okay yeah you you screwed that one up
you're all for one all right here we go
luda watch out for my outfits ridiculous
in the club looking so
uh
you delicious oh absolutely not
oh bad millennial right
conspicuous right no let's get this
straight i'm only 22 years old and i
agree with watch i mean i'm listening to
a lot i know this is a little i know i
got you this is this is like my era
that's right usher
but these are atlanta's rappers so
that's why we got this team you should
have this one this is a all-time
atlanta
tandem okay hint tandem all right
hope that we feel like this feel this
way forever
you can play on a pretty picnic but
damn i got him how do you not know this
i am the old white guy in the front
okay no we're blaming him
for going to rap songs in his era it's
his issue but that was outcast miss
jackson you know you can plant a pretty
picnic but you can't predict the weather
give him a fish question let's go all
right fishbowl question fishbowl
question damn
all you go ahead something off the cuff
here
what's the first live concert you
attended
bro oh travis scott was
insane at coachella first time it was
amazing
i
went home wearing all white came back
wearing all black man you were at
coachella too huh that's that's baller
stuff but i would expect that from you
it was so fun though yeah i bet one day
a bucket list all right well hey juju
it's great seeing you and
congratulations on everything you've
done it's been amazing watch i remember
talking to you before the draft nobody
knew what round you're going to be where
you were going to go but it's worked out
incredibly well for you on the field and
off the field keep it up and uh great
talking to you we hope to talk to you
again down the road yeah thank you there
it is juju smith's shoes to have more
from the super bowl right here at pfc
pfce the mandu
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports